breathing's from podcast Ville its
February 7th you got seven days to buy
your sweetheart a [ __ ] box of
chocolates so you can give it a hard
when you understand it this podcast is
brought to you by 23andme listen we live
in a world where we have access to data
that gives us more personal insights
into who we are what we are where we
came from
what's more personalized in your DNA now
we can turn that into our genetics for
personalized health and wellness
information - when it really and may
allows you to get I mean deep sleep
reports alcohol flush reports reaction
reports sweet vs. salty taste reports
saturated fat and weight report I mean
that's just the top beside telling you
where you're from where your ancestors
are from commit to a healthier you
inspired by your genes with 23andme
health and ancestry service what I'm
going to do is this 20 of me how can
ancestry create is a perfect gift
the Valentine's Day think about it no
more chocolates none of that stuff a
23andme
ancestry kit with the health packet buy
your kit a at 23andme calm slash church
again that's 23andme dot-com slash
church 23andme what's better what a
better gift to give somebody that you
love this podcast is also brought to you
by on it
listen when it comes to supplements or
be knows what the hell he's saying on it
is king do you follow me from the Alpha
brand to the shrimp export should I
shoot a commune I love the Mexican
chocolate milkshake they got beef jerky
they got it all for you go to Anna
comrade now I'm press in church and get
10% off delivered to your door take this
mother [ __ ] meal Lee Rudy Sarzo in
the house the mother [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh sharpening his knives
getting ready to [ __ ] lint and you
got uncle Joey here what's happening you
bad [ __ ] thank you I hope you
don't worry about length oh right like
this is an expression whatever the [ __ ]
it's pretty soon though it's creeping up
on you one day you're walking around
next day [ __ ] white bee
matches on that and you gotta give
something up you gotta give something up
Rudy ever give up anything for Lent
no never no I mean I got nothing else
left
I give up [ __ ] for like every year I
remember the first time I saw people
with the I freaked out oh yeah they just
came from the Jewish lightning they just
run the house they got ashes on their
face why else would you put ash and your
[ __ ] face I'm saying we live in
sensitive times and that poor governor
[ __ ] poor governor they gone after
him for his a [ __ ] med school yearbook
because he has him with a picture of a
Ku Klux Klan and he had blackface on and
people are losing their minds first of
all did you even go to med school why
the [ __ ] do you care and [ __ ] poor
guy we want to make a big deal about
anything for that that put he and he
loved Michael Jackson he said he put
dark face on one time for a Michael
Jackson party and he wore the slippers
they even asked them can you moonwalk
and there's white told a lot that world
news tonight tremendous there's some
[ __ ] up [ __ ] going on freedom of
speech enough the third online said he
did it to everyone just cop into it
before they get caught yeah okay listen
yeah one time in 1983 oh it was Aspen
Colorado they have the second biggest
mall walk which called a wall crawl in
Colorado boulders number one obviously
the homeless people get in on it they
play the drums
it's a [ __ ] sting fest Haley's got
those Birkenstock enzyme with their feet
smelling like goat [ __ ] and Aspen had
the same thing so I came to an
electrical company that I work that me
Jimmy Buerkle god rest his soul and Cato
I had an idea we were 19 years old I
think Jimmy was 21 we were 19 years old
we were gonna dress up with long thermal
underwear and white sneakers and put a
hanger around our necks and go to the
mall who all has abortions what hey what
happened monday night football started
[ __ ] 7:00 we had a quaalude
and we passed out likely the dis Super
Bowl and we woke up at midnight with
these [ __ ] hangers around our neck
and well I thank God we didn't go up
there thank God
so when I do that young Zion it was
tasteless it was a tasteless thing to do
at the age of 19 which we've all done
something tasteless at the age of 19 you
know at least a guy was in [ __ ] med
school but this is the society I'm
petrified of that they can just pull
something out of your [ __ ] high
school yearbook
thank God I can quit school see the
advantages of [ __ ] not being in the
yearbook and getting a GED and this
crazy how times change though you think
about it like they were okay with that
picture being in the yearbook
it's a KKK guy and a black guy in
blackface I'll get it out with a [ __ ]
Budweiser I like Americans like you
Americans having a good time I could see
if they were there drinking German beer
and they were part-time Nazis as I'm
like that dressed up for the [ __ ]
blackface
but they have you know they didn't
having a good time in a dorm room
cracking jokes first off the commercial
racism is something that you have to
eliminate that reaction early on like I
I knew when I got to New York City in
1967 that the word [ __ ] I knew what it
meant I had been called to spit on 88th
Street a couple of times I didn't know
how to react and I went to my mom and I
asked her and she flung her cigarette
took the swig of her beer and she's like
don't call you a nickname they don't
like she just turned around and walked
away and I was like you know what she's
right at least they call you a [ __ ]
[ __ ] I can see if they'll call you
nothing and then you just learned to
deal with it and then I started going up
to 148 Street where the white kids hung
out with Puerto Ricans and they weren't
allowed to say that word spring they
would say it but even you had to get
desensitized
you know you had to get desensitized
they taught you like your mom and those
days would say shut up sticks and stones
will break you
but words will never hurt you that was
the old adage my first friend was black
his name was Jasper Williams and they
used to call him Casper Jasper the
Friendly Ghost like they would torment
him and call him a ghost and all this
[ __ ] that he was the only black ghost
why his father call him Jasper and I mmm
dealing with it right now I know
wherever Jasper is in this world if you
call him and then he'll just flank his
arm line it we've been listening to it
since I was 10
you're not gonna do nothing to me it's
not effective it's not effective how do
you feel about it what was the first
time you got called this spring ever oh
yeah
in what's later yeah but you know the
way I figure is you know ignorance you
know and this person is calling me names
because he's probably never socialized
or met anybody like me so he's only
their only reference is from somebody
else's experience or reference so it is
my my responsibility to let this person
know what this latino guano person is
really like just put it Brandon me by a
random identification such as a [ __ ] it
doesn't make any sense you you you don't
know who I am
you never been to my house but here let
me show you who I am you know and then
then you can call me a friend you can
call me a neighbor whatever you want but
first let me give me the option to
educate you on Who I am and hopefully
you can get a sense of who my people are
like from knowing me you know usually
thinks you know it's it's like ignorance
breeds racism you know in my
neighborhood we are
I got a Russian across the street we
have up four Americans down the street I
have six right next door I mean it's
it's like a little it's a melting pot
we're all neighbors when the holidays
come we'll
give gifts no matter what our religious
background is to each other we respect
each other because we know each other
you know and into and to me that from
traveling around the world the more you
get to know people around the world the
more you realize how much in common we
really have as human beings we're all in
the same planet you know and what
happens is is through generations and
poor references of history things that
happened during history you know that
people hand down through generations
negative identities to certain religious
groups or Co or societies or cultures
you know just because they don't know
who these people are once you go to
their country you visit them like Russia
you know I grew up during the Cold War
and the propaganda was there Russian
women there were all fat ugly and and
horrible I once I traveled to Russia and
you know and even former Russian
Republic Soviet republics like the
Ukraine and Belarus and you know so on
they are the most beautiful women that
I've met in in Europe and all of Europe
you know I I believe the United States
has the most beautiful women in the
world because it's a combination of all
the countries coming in to America you
know and and bringing all you know the
finest example of people to the United
States but if you go to Europe I mean
some of them you know the most beautiful
women you're gonna meet are actually
Russian I mean do you think that your
travel is part of the reason why both of
you don't get caught up in a lot of this
because a you've been you've met all
different types of people so you've been
a verbal attacked or abused by everybody
you've heard everything but then you've
also on the flipside gotten to meet
every different kind of person and
you've made friends with them so you
it's hard to hate them and you're
friends with oh that's like Jimmy I do
you think that if you hadn't traveled
but you would have been a little bit
more close-minded I don't travel you
should do no I don't I travel in the
country I don't travel abroad I just
decided on how that word felt early on
and I knew that if you have to pick your
battles when you're a kid on the street
you gotta pick your battles so in those
days in the early 70s I'm gonna try on
got there was a bunch of tough kids in
this neighborhood kids you didn't
protect your honor as much as your
mother
the big word was mother [ __ ] if I
called your mother [ __ ] you had a
fight and then your reply was keeping
mother off the street and I won't [ __ ]
it and then we would have to throw
punches or something game with a bottle
so respect you just let go in those days
it was your mother or if they called you
or a gay name you know then you had a
[ __ ] throw punches that's just the
way it was so nobody could really say
nothing about your mother in those days
your mother's your mother was sacred
when I came from Cuba those kids I ran
with you can say nothing about that
mother they'd be on top here before you
send up so you let the spit go you know
and when I when I was growing up in 88
Street it was a very yeah my little
girlfriend was Chinese her father was a
draw for Charles Schultz and we would go
to the for me as her Snoopy - [ __ ] in
kindergarten in the first grade I was
very tired with that family they would
give me candy with paper on it and [ __ ]
for Christmas but everybody else in that
neighborhood was predominantly white and
that's where I could what was called the
strike but I didn't really give a [ __ ]
like I had I was overcoming language
barriers I got it and I'm gonna get into
it until this day it haunts me that
there was a laundry mat across the
street from 205 West 88th Street and I
went across the street and a mother
pulled me over until this day
it was to stay away from a daughter
because I was Spanish like I thought
about that conversation for a long time
she said some of you yeah all right
little girl was cute I was cute she was
in my class or something you know we
would walk together and one day she
pulled me aside and she goes you can't
walk with us or something like that and
I wasn't hurt that he I'm telling you
guys it says madam ladies I wasn't hurt
I wasn't surprised so when I started
going up to my godmothers house I'm not
in 48th Street the reception was so much
different to me being Spanish even from
the white kids the white kids were
taking me to the house to eat before the
Puerto Ricans and they were in white
they were [ __ ] tough Irish white
trash that would live and die for you if
I still remembered their names I would
fly out and meet them and podcast them
expose our world to them but those days
what we did how we made money then there
was the sedan your family they were a
Puerto Rican family had nine kids and
they lived in a two bedroom and
everybody slept on the floor with fans
you never seen nothing like that so here
I was living on 88th Street Rudy with my
own bedroom with air conditioning with
my own stereo in my room but on the
weekends I would go to my godmother has
seen how people really lived so I would
play my money down I would play my money
where do you live I would say in Jersey
I would never say 88th Street I would
never say those kids taught me about
being a thankful and how their parents
worked all day and they wouldn't see
their dads and moms and you know it was
a different world up there but that's
where the words picked got taken away
and then I moved to Jersey and in Jersey
everybody calls respect what's the
neighborhood I moved them everybody
calls you speck and there was the only
two specks in that neighborhood it was
me and Carlos Perez so now that was a
different challenge
challenger was I would be aspect until I
could prove to these savages that I was
crazy or as crazy as they would and then
thus pick one away and that's exactly
what I did you know I had the same
experience because when you and I
arrived in the United States there
weren't done many Latinos no Ricky
Ricardo was the only one everybody loved
if you didn't know Ricky Ricardo you
weren't [ __ ] if you see winner yeah when
we were relocated to Jersey afterwards I
had that experience but when I arrived
in Miami in 1961 we had a we were second
what was considered second generation of
Cubans arriving because the first
generation were the the upper class that
left Cuba right Bautista yeah yeah pre
Bautista Bautista and a lot of them as
soon as the Revolution happened they
jump in their yachts and and went to
Miami to to actually live in their
summer homes because they had you know
homes in in Cuba and homes in Miami so I
I met a lot of girls who their parents
actually you know were industrialists
you know people that own industries in
Cuba and they were actually living in
Miami but in their their vacation home
basically you know and so when I got
there in 61 because they took my parents
somebody over a year to get all the work
you know the the visas you know the visa
and the passport and then you know we'll
have somebody claim as you know we go we
came here legally and but so by the time
we got in we're still you know we move
right into Southwest las always Sarah
you know in Miami which is it was
basically a few blocks of just it was a
Cuban ghetto just all families from Cuba
moving in and what happens is okay while
the parents were struggling to make a
living the kids we were misplaced
mentally you know we just didn't know
how to handle it except to get the anger
of us being in a foreign country trying
to assimilate trying to adapt not really
knowing very much how to do it because
your parents
we're doing making two jobs and I have
to take care of my little brother
because my mom and dad had to go to work
so all this Sunday I'm babysitting my
little brother who was maybe at the time
seven years old you know and I'm 11 and
it's like how am I gonna I've never done
this before
so you know you're kind of like now
you're protecting your brother you're
trying to get an identity you're dealing
with other Cuban kids who are pissed off
too so it all came down to what you're
talking about
each you know a lot of confrontations
all the time not from outsiders but from
our own because we were misplaced
we just didn't even know how to fit in
because as soon as you left the
neighborhood you went to school that's a
whole that's a whole you know story
because now you're you're in the school
with like the first generation of Cubans
that got there now that they felt a
little bit superior to you because they
have been there for two years now so
they were experienced you know in the
American culture and society then you
have lo americano and they just don't
want to have anything to do with you
because they thought well first of all
these guys were going to be gone from
here you know very soon because the
whole think you but it's gonna be
resolved and well you know 50 years
later it still has something resolved
you know 60 years later so yeah I had to
deal with a lot of that and then on top
of that once we were relocated to New
Jersey that was a whole set of
circumstances that as a kid was very
tough in my high school there was the
white cafeteria and the jocks cafeteria
no there was a split cafeteria would you
Spanish kids went in today and I would
go on between both was it official from
the school it was a unofficial so nobody
got their feelings hurt that's what the
[ __ ] ain't and the teachers ain't that
so really gonna make it look bad the
teachers had a lounge in there okay but
that's where I'll never forget one of my
favorite teachers of all time was
talking to me and father
place and while he was talking to me
from a distance a kid walked in between
him and stepped on his shoes and mr. t
looked over his pardon me I think it
goes what happening us next time get
your hoop doop doop a ring shoes off my
feet however forget dyeing my a thought
it was offended hoop to see the merengue
shoes off my feet and the kid nearly
died but it was official but unofficial
did the Cuban kids minded not really
they were just happy to be in this
country David just happen to be in this
country somebody put up my sixth-grade
picture the other day sixth grade mr.
King walls class nor was seventh grade
mr. Levine oh the [ __ ] got left
me back and in that class there were
three kids that you can obviously tell
when not twelve years old
well his name was Juan so no the other
kid's name was lazarino ver law and I
forget what the other kid's name what
they worshiped in the seventh grade in
those days if you hadn't been in the
American system for too long because it
was taking you too long to learn in
English they would just keep in the
seventh grade like two or three times
and by that time Luis Zaldivar I was
starting to get a beard I wish it was
another girl put it up so I couldn't
take it down from her thing or really
share it I tried but it wouldn't let me
share it and it shows me in the top with
like a white t-shirt I will like this
[ __ ] pornographic shirt on the Miss
Laurie nose class but toast wrote Juan
Soto quit school in the seventh grade
cuz he knocked the girl up and he had to
go to work I'll never forget still
walking home with him on his last day in
school and him telling me brah gotta go
load trucks tomorrow he was how old are
you in the seventh grade they pulled me
back one grade when we came here so hold
me usually in the seventh grade he was
fifteen yeah he was fifteen yeah
probably skip a couple of years yeah it
was
fifteen he already was a man in the
sixth seventh grade and they were gonna
skip him little has a read over law they
pulled him was seeing him punched a
principal in the [ __ ] head when a
strain on one day in the basement when I
was even lodged by myself
I saw them say something the Laza reader
allows of you total [ __ ] off and the
teacher got in his face and before the
teacher could even square lazarino
caught him in the jaw where there was
straight arm and the teacher was legs
went out from under us trying to walk
and they kept saying I'm dead I'm going
to the office I mean that's how tough
those kids were but they would hold you
back until you were in the language I'm
enough I'm not saying it's racist or
whatever I'm just saying that they
wanted you to speak enough English to at
least be able to move around in high
school these guys were refusing to do it
there's Cubans that have got me in 1959
that still refused to learn the language
because they always thought they were
gonna go back to Cuba and it was gonna
be a waste at that time my parents my
mom and dad they didn't learn English
until I left like I live I had left home
they were just those you know them to my
mom and dad living at home so they have
free time so they started going to a
night school to learn English my dad
never really learned it my mom picked up
with some of it enough because then
again no matter how much English you
learn when you're Miami first of all you
learn from Cuban teachers that don't
necessarily have the best accent you
know second of all there's nobody really
in Miami to practice it with because all
do the Cuban specially in the area that
my mom lives they all speak Spanish how
do you when you would stuff it when
would stop you here oh yeah well I wish
I was born in 1950 so I must have been
what stuck was 69 69 yeah 1818 do you
remember the event yeah
yeah but I heard about it on the radio I
was 18 I was already playing bars in
Miami so it wasn't like
you know III had commitments you know
locally so it wasn't like I was you know
gonna hop in the car and drive all the
way to Woodstock you know I had gigs do
you gaze yeah
how did you feel the idea was the center
would stop
you know the arm i have it here or
whatever i just put on the santana parts
oh no I was watching on YouTube
do you remember hearing Santana for the
first well remember yeah I did you see
gave me hope for all for the first time
you know I because I completely
understood being born in Cuba and having
afro-cuban music the foundation of what
my musical background is you know I was
listening to up for Cuban music or even
you know Sally a guru on the la se da
you know any of that music before I came
to United States before rock-and-roll
because we're talking early 50s you know
and so when I came to America then you
have blues bass rock and roll and if you
look at it they're all off of Cuban
music blues bass rock'n'roll it's all
comes from the same African influence so
that's what Santana did he blended both
the afro-cuban and the blues into one
sound and there you go it to me that is
the best representation of rock music he
did spectacularly Oh fantastic yeah even
the UH night I heard the one he did it
Rob Thomas thirty years later yeah he's
still added to a snow or Mentos yeah
that's Spanish
yeah actually the the first musician to
incorporate in there in American
influence music which is jazz to
incorporate Latin rhythms was was a
Dizzy Gillespie with Manteca when he had
Manteca in the group and Duke Ellington
had some of that you know if you listen
to Caravan he has a you know a lot of
Latin percussion in there but actually
as a sound as a direction of a group
Dizzy Gillespie went into Latin jazz
well dizzy went to Cuba yeah yeah he did
go to money when did he get influenced
with like jazz
after women taker joined the band or
before Cuba oh yeah well I see I would
know I don't know if dizzy had actually
met Manteca and Cuba or they met in New
York City but that was the biggest
influence he had Nam on deck I was
wasn't percussionist oh yeah pretty good
yeah wasn't that you know what they call
them Mantegna really one yeah my deck I
yeah so who was the guy he was visiting
in Cuba dizzy he became friends with
then they get him out yeah my first but
the wife was a communist she didn't
really want to leave that was a no yeah
the only story I know it's what I saw in
the HBO made for you know right yeah
somebody reached out to me and said that
a Toro sand of our jr. either does a
radio show or a podcast and he wanted me
to go on I just don't know much about
his father and his roots I just solved
from what I know in that HBO movie yeah
and then I asked a couple for you Cubans
know like October was cool his wife was
the commie [ __ ] so I can't really you
know go on this all I know about the
first time I met him it was 1994 on a
Billboard Awards Latin billboard award
in Miami somebody introduced me to him
and they told him which I was or going
on tour actually doing a show in Russia
in 1994 with Whitesnake and when he
hears that I'm going to rush it just
like he just threw his arms up in the
air and says man you freaked out because
he just didn't want to you know that was
a bad experience for him the whole
communist you know communism in Cuba
experience for him was awful when you
went to Russia would you see I you know
let me know exactly what I saw from the
stage of course you know we went there
with a promoter you know and when you go
there on a what it's called is this 1994
you know so when you go there on a
almost a what I call that you know a
government you know a goodwill tour you
know
what I saw this was it was my experience
and it just it just it was incredibly
moving for me to be on stage and watch
grown men crying because we were playing
the music that just a few years before
it was they could have gone to jail for
listening to it because rock and roll
was outlawed during the the whole
communist regime in in Russia you know
so for them to finally feel free that
wasn't that was freedom and I was moving
and moved to tears because still in my
country my own country you know my my
country of birth because the US is my
country by my country of birth it's
still it's still a communist country you
know and and it's just it just gave me
hope that the place that the birthplace
of communism is not communist anymore
you know but my country still that my
country of birth still is but it just
gave me hope that hopefully someday you
know it will be free again the new the
scorpion's go over there to a bunch of
oh yeah yes yes that's where I've got
before before we actually play there
what we were doing was it's called the
white knights festival white nice is
because at the end of June
it's it for about a week the Sun does
not set you know it's just daylight it's
noise white nights and we landed a
midnight and it was like like noon you
know basically so we went you know
straight to some big party going on in
some some embassy or something and then
which is sweet we were there for like
five days you know before we did the
show and we went to the museums and we
you know we were taking care of
fantastic you know it was really great
and we got to meet the people and you
got to find out that everybody will have
one thing in common you know we want to
have be able to provide for our families
give our families the best life possible
and I found Russia one of the most
religious countries that I've ever
visited
because it was religion that gave them
hope if you look book of the churches in
Russia
they were the best maintained churches
because Stanley knew and this is
according to the locals because I asked
a lot of questions while I was there you
know becoming from a communist country
myself I asked him a lot of questions so
Chaz Wow I was not I did not realize
that churches you know it still existed
in Russia and their answer was it says
they say look you know we styling knew
that he could not take God away from the
people he could not take Hope faith away
from them so he just turned a blind eye
to to certain you know like Christmases
and certain religious dates and led the
people celebrate them but it was not an
official government sanctioned
celebration it was just something that
the people did on their own so they
maintained the churches the people
themselves maintained the churches
really really well so later on the
churches you know every time when I
would because I've done a lot of tours
in Russia ever since you know with do
and certain some other bands and every
time you arrive in a and it's any in a
town in the middle of Russia you go to
the the center of the city and there
would be a beautiful church maintained
you know the dome and all painted in
gold and all of that so you know I think
that's us that's that gave the the
people during the Communist era a lot of
hope and a lot of faith otherwise they
don't think that they would have been
able to survive it
how was you staying with Whitesnake how
was it yeah only there for me I joined a
band in 87 and my last show was in 94
seven [ __ ] years yeah
actually I recorded one us slip of the
tongue we tour on the 87 record that was
the director was done before the the
band the band joined you know that's
when the big and Campbell Agent
Vandenberg Tommy Aldridge and I joined
the band for the making of slip of the
still of the night video and then we
stayed in in the group
we just you know kept be members so my
fact Tommy Aldridge is still as a member
of a fly snake they're about to tour
yeah
they're they you know all these bands
Def Leppard Whitesnake everybody they
they go on tour it every year what is
that [ __ ] tell you I mean the music
is really timeless people you know you
do it not only are you performing for
the the the older fans you know the
other core fans but you're also you're
you're performing for the new generation
of fans and then you would we toured
with them 284 White's 91-94 yeah yeah I
was an Aussie from the 81 to 82 I
rejoined what is known as the mental
health version of qui arrive because
there was the Randy Rhoads version of
choir right before that in 82 I rejoined
that as a matter of fact I recorded
speak of the devil and and started
working on mental health at at the same
time exactly you know like I did one
record and then I came back to LA and
continued working on the other record
you know so it's as a matter fact I in
in the 80s I recorded five consecutive
multi-platinum albums in the 80s in a
row
I did the a tribute album which is life
without without with Randy I did the
speak of the devil which is the real
recordings of Black Sabbath mental
health condition critical and slip of
the tongue
all of them multi-platinum three
different bands yeah I want the house I
saw Jesus Christ what is it like when
you start hearing that an album you work
on cuz platinum will means what ten
million no 1 million 1 million yet Gold
is half a million platinum is 1 and then
multi-platinum to start going to 2 3 4
and so on
Diamond is 10 million diamond like that
that's such a crazy number 2 you just
record in the studio and I know you're
going on tour so you have an idea that
people like you but take have a million
people buy an album that must be praised
yeah because they have to buy the record
or in whatever format they have to buy
it in vinyl or CD or cassette or the
ones once it started going into
streaming like we have today it's a
whole different ballgame you know but
what emotions did you remember the first
album he had that went platinum well
let's see if I'm going chronologically
because okay actually the first one that
I received that was platinum was not a
record that I played on but it was
actually a record that I toured on okay
it was one of them was a blizzard and
the other one diary you know and and
people online you know social media to
say hey how come you got a you know a
platinum record or gold record for
something usually not play on it's
because if you look at the plaque the
plaque clearly says to commemorate the
cell of so many records right in your
name that's why when you go to a
lawyer's office they have gold records
on the wall because they were the
lawyers representing the artists for the
record deal you go to a dentist it could
be the guy who did the veneers for the
singer he gets a gold record you can
give a record gold record to your
parents you know it doesn't necessarily
mean that you play it on the record I
received it because I toured and I was
kind of like the the sales person on
stage for I'm wrong with a band selling
selling those records I gotta take this
back because I was within the car my
wife the other night and one of your
albums came on one of your songs came up
and my wife read about you and she goes
he played on this but they took him
office no that wasn't me all right you
did not do blizzard of Ozz it was not
you and you really not record no that
was that was Bob Daisley yes and my
friend Liz ER and diary were recorded
before Tommy Aldridge and I joined the
band yeah no [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah I wrote about her in my book I
thought she a clear I thought you wrote
him oh no and then she took the bass
lines out - you don't get any money what
would that happen but I had nothing to
do with me
what do you mean that I'm what I'm what
out well there is a version of blizzard
of Ozz and diary that was re-recorded by
other musicians but I'm not involved in
that
yeah I wasn't even in the band I mean it
would that happened like years after I
left
Ozzy so when they first did the first
blizzard that's still Randy oh yeah okay
that's right yeah you know Randy is in
every single version the a blizzard and
diary of a madman okay we're talking
about is when those records were the
rhythm section the drums and the bass
were replaced by different rhythm
section but that was like way after I
left the band they had nothing to do
with me so okay so Tommy Bob whatever
basically Randy and Ozzy do the first
out no no Leo leakers lately curly curly
Frankie right he P in the first album
yeah and the second they did it
back-to-back it's like they also say toe
and all that was done all in one shot we
have a madman all that was done in one
shot
and blizzard well blizzard was recorded
then they they did a small like out like
a tour okay yeah they will the EP yet
all that and then they did diary and
what once diary was in the can that's
when they they decided to let go of Bob
and Lee and get Tommy Tommy was in the
band before I joined the band then they
got me in the band Randy got me okay and
that's the thing that's the band that
toured blizzard and dancing yeah so yeah
[ __ ] yeah you told it I mean you know I
I did as much to get those you know to
earn those gold records as a lawyer or
the dentist that has to put gold records
on the wall you know
well you know man I'm sure you added
your own type of licks in your own type
of style to those way so whether or not
they kept my nouns they kept buying
hounds after yeah absolutely and you
know it's yeah it's your hire to do
something elaborate this way for wasn't
me it would have been somebody else you
know and I'm glad it was me and while I
was there I was I was just respecting
and celebrating what the what was played
on the record and just like everybody
should I was sticking basically to what
was on the record that everybody was
familiar with you know you can't you
shouldn't reinvent the wheel you know
it's it's it's it's a great record so
just play it as it is very simple never
taking any credit for being the guy who
played on it because that I that's not
me who wants to do that that's crazy you
know you have to respect and you know
people's contributions you know and
celebrate them you know and later on you
know I got to record you know do the
mental health record before I joined the
band there were two songs that were
already recorded and it's credited the
current bass player Chuck Wright he
recorded mental health and don't wanna
let you go and do you know the story how
I got to go back into my riot
oh okay so Randy had died you know in
the plane crash
and I wasn't a break from touring with
Ozzy there's like in the summertime late
summer and in 1982 and I get a phone
call from Kevin Dubrow and he says
listen do you want to come in and we're
we're working on a record it was not
officially a name quiet yet because
there was no record deal yet it was a
production deal
so Kevin goes and we're gonna be doing
you know we're gonna we're gonna cut
Thunderbird now Thunderbird was a song
that that Kevin wrote for Randy when
Randy left Quiet Riot and when Randy
left Quiet Riot I was doing there
from projects around town I was in a
band called angel also I was living with
Kevin and he had a band named Dubrow so
you know he asked me to play with him so
I did I played in Dubrow his own band
and one of the songs that we that we
perform was Thunderbirds so I was very
familiar with the song so I walked in to
the studio to do just one song and we
cut it really quickly because I knew it
so it was like you know okay it's done
and then there was like three hours left
of studio time and so the producer turns
to me and says do you remember any of
the older songs because metal health'
the album well a lot of the songs on
that were actually songs from the band
called Dubrow that Kevin already had you
know so he got rebranded as Quiet Riot
you know so by the time that I left the
session I had recorded slick black
Cadillac let's get crazy you know songs
that slick black Cadillac data back to
the Randy era of Quiet Riot that was the
only song that was a broad and from that
Randy Rhoads Quiet Riot into the mental
health version of Quiet Riot the slick
black Cadillac and you know so by the
time I left the session I had done about
four songs already I was not in the band
officially I just went in for a session
but I gotta tell you the joy that I that
I could have connected with the joy that
I found that I actually lost from
playing with Ozzy after Randy died I
felt it again
being in the room with you know Frankie
who I was I have played with him I grew
up playing with Frankie in Florida but
now Benelli yeah so you know della I
started playing with him back in 72 so
ten years later we're in the studio in
LA cutting this record that nobody ever
thought was gonna do anything dumb wound
up to be the first debut metal record to
go to number one so you know so I even
and and I saw I start feeling like wow
you know I think I think I found my joy
of playing again you know playing with
with Kevin and playing with
Frankie and Carlos cavasso who I knew
from the circuit he was in a band called
snow you know we used to play same gigs
and stuff like that so you know I you
gotta follow the you joy you know in
life you if if you're if for whatever
reason such as in my case you know what
- Randy died it was it was painful
painful to continue being in the band
every night without him there ah I I
made the decision to leave one of the
biggest bands in the world just to
follow my my joy of making music you
know they do the right move you know
well I mean you know four years later
you have with the right move but back
then except for my wife who was my
girlfriend at the time she never said a
word she never said oh you know the
really you really think you should leave
Ozzy you know she didn't she just just
and she's always been like that my wife
has been incredibly supportive you know
she's never would have back then Oh an
81 yeah yeah yeah I'm mad about my wife
and uh September 1981 yeah
let me ask you this why haven't you put
together like a whole [ __ ] Spanish
fusion of your afro background with some
I do okay black dude thing in the back
and I did it for my folks because you
know my folks only knew me as playing an
American you know rock and roll and so I
put this these songs together and and
just just for my folks you know just
with them but I'm going to set him to
you know I'm happy now how does it feel
to be doing your own podcast and radio
show yeah you know I thank you for the
inspiration because I gotta tell you you
know coming to on your show on your
podcast and and realizing how important
it is to do these podcasts and I gotta
tell you why you know in our in our
world in music we own
get to show people get to know us
through our music and now through social
media they might get a glimpse of who we
really are
don't you know anybody commit can
manipulate social media
anybody can present a certain profile of
like I am a very nice person and I love
puppies and I love kitties and you know
I give to the homeless people but that
could be manipulated you know that could
be not necessarily be the real deal I
believe on a podcast
you can't fake it because it's a
conversation if I'm gonna be insincere
you're gonna call me out during a
podcast I'm sure you've done it before
you know or you might do it in the
future to somebody who's gonna come on
your podcast and and you know and not be
really honest with you know during the
podcast so I thought I had I had a case
one time when I brought a guy in for a
second chance type podcast not a second
chance with me I didn't judge him like
that but a second chance and when he
folded on me the first time it was like
I turned my chin just focused on me
because there was no reason to go
forward if he wasn't going to come to
terms with what he had done it was the
weirdest thing it was a little hot
weirdest podcast me and we cover that
turned out to be a good podcast but once
I saw that there's been a couple times
of people come on and there are
different people they're different
person that when they walk in the door
they walk in the door they're [ __ ]
off someone here they they and I saw it
Joe either never came on the podcast
yeah I always thought I can't imagine to
live let's say I wasn't doing comedy
this was not happening I was working at
a car wash and I found out Rudy Sarzo
did a podcast I listened to it I was a
fan of yours in 1981 I saw the pictures
I read the articles but I know if I
listened to you
I'm gonna get to know you I'm gonna tell
you I [ __ ] hate it I tell you what I
[ __ ] hate it for years I like the
band but it'll light looking at him
except for Tommy Lee Tommy Lee I can
tolerate the other three I couldn't
tolerate now today I kind of like Mickey
six why because that [ __ ] radio show
oh yeah and even though he's a dick on
that radio show to people sometimes come
with it I like it because it shows me
who he is
yeah now I know who he wasn't that bad
yeah I listened to him on the radio now
I know who he wasn't that bad and why
that band was successful
that was Motley Crue but that was
Nicky's band you know you listen and you
I can't imagine at this point not doing
a podcast I always knew that if I could
get my story out there and explain to
people what happened as bad as good as
there was that I'd do a little better
and I was correct because when you're on
stage the whole time guys making jokes
and then he leaves and maybe you might
follow him on social media you don't
really get to know the real him
I know people that have come up to me
and said I really don't like your
material but you answered my email back
and I came here because of that
character I emailed three other comics
they didn't email me back you follow me
so he gets to see people the other
aspects of your life lets us see people
that you are a dog lover when I'm on
stage I'm watching you're hitting your
head up and down like a [ __ ] Zombo on
the bass I don't know I think you leave
down run over animals right if you saw
something else stays doing this for two
hours they leave and they hit oh they
hit them dog with an animal they don't
give a [ __ ] they had brain - a different
seat - here I got to know you were an
animal lover you know these are the
things at the end of the day people
really want
everybody's got a poster on there well
that's why I hate when celebrity if you
get a [ __ ] Twitter account twit don't
give me the false hope
that you're not gonna tweet tweet you
open up an account to interact to keep
you relevant tweet if somebody says I
was your biggest fan growing up take the
two minutes and go hey man thank you
even though I retired from basketball in
1989 there's still 50 year olds that
still remember you I think it's very
important think of if you had a show you
want Seinfeld one of the biggest shows
of our time or friends once those shows
end you got so much money you really
don't want to do dick the first six
months you've been overwhelmed with
questions and stupidities and jokes and
six days a week and 80 hours but after
those six months it now comes Mike and
Molly and you lose those friends to Mike
and Molly no more you can retain 50% of
that fan base by telling the people how
you experiences were on that show and
now what do they got they got a [ __ ]
cash register I don't like them I
personally couldn't go home and sit
there but they got a thing called
comic-con right and music on you could
go there with headshots and [ __ ]
drumsticks and make a half million
dollars a year nobody knows what the
[ __ ] you're doing you could tell the
government you sold one drumstick and
you shovel up your ass they're broke and
then I love yourself 50 or 100 that's
even a bigger scam this microphone
doesn't guarantee you a bunch of stuff
it guarantees relevancy if you want a
band for 10 years and if you retain 33
friends then we'll start with 33 people
and we'll work it upwards and then she
filled her whole girlfriend do you
listen to Joey Diaz no I listen to Rudy
Sarzo what's really the bass player what
the [ __ ] he talking about listen and I
go and hear you talk about I remember
snorting coke with Ozzy and he stuck a
finger up my ass no and all sudden
you're a human fan you're a human being
Rudy you're talking about Christ and
about the dogs and about opening
for uriah heep and these new baselines
you're working on and you know you
working on animation I'm like [ __ ] I'm
into Rudy this is not what I expected I
wanted to hear him talk about Ozzy and
snore dance with Motley Crue and hitting
people in the head with bottles
you're not mentioning that you know I
always make it a point here on this show
not to talk about what people want me to
talk about and that's exactly what I
learned from you because I did I think
this is my fourth port podcast
fourth or fifth yeah you've done other
ones and I've listened to the other ones
in your grade up yeah but you know
there's something there there's
definitely a specific connection from
where we come from that it's it's it's a
little a little bit deeper you know from
from the other time you know
conversations that I have because we get
to talk about things that I don't get to
talk about with it with everybody you
know so the connection gets gets a
little you know deeper more profound you
know but it's the honesty in in the show
the exit very your show is a very honest
show and I learned that and that's what
I try to do on my podcast because that's
a musician you know first to sort of
play music's I saw the Beatles and the
chicks were screaming at the Beatles I
want that you know I wasn't a musician I
was just a guy that want to be noticed
by chicks right and then later on you
know like I stuck with it and became a
musician and realize that what we do
every single note that we play we're
looking for the truth the truth there's
a lot of [ __ ] in life
we're bombarded by [ __ ] man and if I
can put my bass on and I will all my
myself sitting in my cell phone with him
a little fire next to me on my guitar
and my little dog and the back of my
neck sitting on top of the couch and I
just sit there and I'm not trying to
impress anybody I'm just looking for the
truth I'm looking for that what I'm
gonna play now it's gonna move me move
me in a way that I have never been moved
before I not even in front of hundreds
of thousands of people
you know and that is something that
honesty that honesty is what I live for
you know every day I try to remove more
[ __ ] that gets in the way of my
creativity every day every day because
they're just distractions you know and
this is what I learned from doing your
podcasts keeping it real keeping it
honest I rather I don't even like that
we're in the cat Comley category there's
no tie come on to the show I'm not
looking for the joke I'm looking for the
story and from the story humor will grow
we our job is to find the humor from the
story my niece was over last night my
wife was talking every time my niece and
I were talking about something serious
and my wife would make a remark and I
finally looked down and I go ask my
niece of you and get a [ __ ] backhand
that this is our neighborhood you would
have got punched in the [ __ ] head it
would've told you to knock at the [ __ ]
off there's a serious conversation
I like serious conversations I think
from a serious conversation eventually
the lighten up is where you get the
humor
I don't like pushing and I don't like
pushing jokes on it if they're Jos gonna
come on it's gonna come out we'll have a
good time me and Leo giggle yield giggle
I always strive to tell the truth on
these things and get it off my chest
well it was up my chest my my hand I get
to get it off we get to discuss on the
air it's like having your own psychiatry
psychiatrist but only gets put out into
the universe which is even benefit then
talking to one person when I talk to one
person psychiatry takes it home I have
two shots of vodka suck so husband's
dick Utley move the [ __ ] on well I put
it on to the universe it grows as a
culture and that truth some reason it
attached to it and that's what the truth
connects because somebody else related
to that stupid story I told about this
or that or this that's what I worth I'm
doing this if FLE tomorrow comes to me
and says I'm opening up for Ron
white on the road I came to the podcast
mum I wouldn't be Madeleine I would
periscope the periscope the podcast as
long as you kept your weekly message up
and kept a touch of people think about
all those actors that the shows came to
an end and their fans stood that because
I know if you watch not Dharma and Greg
what's the other [ __ ] show that was
about the gay couple in grace willing
grace one of my favorite shows on TV
the only problem were willing Grace
weren't the funniest characters on that
show
it was the skinny gay guy and the chick
she stole the show I wish I could talk
to her you know I'm saying I finally
ended up doing the show with her and I
got some words but I told her you're a
badass [ __ ] she giggled but that's what
we have to say that we didn't have in
the 70s I couldn't talk to Julius Erving
I couldn't talk to David Gilmore in the
70s we have that now you know Gilmore
answer you back in time the time you do
know that right know that he's gotta
know you're more orgasm Club and another
Gilmore Club that puts up pictures but I
follow David Gilmore on periscope and on
Twitter and he'll talk to you from time
to time
have you read the Pete Townsend book no
you got to read it I mean for so many
reasons you know I mean I you who fan
yes or no I've had my moment okay I saw
him live so what you're no no moment
[Music]
Pete Times is a [ __ ] pedophile you
think so did he get caught with a bunch
of explain naked base he explains in the
base naked no hear me Kevin Spacey is in
there he explains they love him ha what
actually had read the book it's in his
book but but he was one of those guys
that you know in the book who reveals a
lot of background stuff that the average
listener of the who was not aware of
like like myself he was a he was working
with a public book publishing company
and he published a lot of books you know
he was responsible for editing them and
all of that he if you joined a fan club
the who fan club he
we'll write you back personally by hand
is before emails he would send you a
written response you know and yeah
that's every our respect I respect I
respect that
always have you know immensely always
the after Tommy the the rock opera every
every who record including who's next
because you got Quadrophenia you have
quad you Fenian who were you on my
favorites yeah but I love Tommy talk
about me all warm on what I bet you
could see my every record every record
after that was actually a a complete
work you know not just a collection of
songs it was a a concept album basically
and except for who's next
because who's next was supposed to be a
a concept record about what he called
the grid now we're talking in the 70s he
had envisioned the internet being the
grid where people could connect with
each other on this grid and that's what
who's next the record really is about
all those songs independently and of
course you know it
what they did is they the who rented out
a theater called the Old Vic and they
wrote em and did the pre-production for
the record on stage with an open door to
anybody that was walking by they could
actually go in and watch him do it you
know write the record life as it was
going on because to them that was a
concept how about if we make a record
and we invite anybody that wants to come
in to watch us do this but for some
reason nobody really showed up except
for some homeless people that were just
sheltering from from the weather going
walking into the theater and just
sitting there watching them perform you
know so he's got some really high
concepts you know and and if you read
the book you're gonna probably gonna
change your mind about
I am [ __ ] being judgemental I just
thought he was a pedophile
you know he explains you know the origin
of that yeah yeah always a [ __ ]
pleasure Rudy you always come in here
and drop now you two I this is not only
the church this is university this is
this is cocoa you so you have the six
degrees 6 degrees of Rudy yeah I'm sorry
seven six degrees of SARS oh yeah on
monsters of rock radio which is part of
the - app - is like if you download it
you go either on your Android or your or
your iPhone you drown download the app
it's free and no subscription no
advertising and it's gotten many
stations you know if you like soul music
or if you like funk if you like metal
monsters or rockets the station to go so
I'm on 4 p.m. Pacific Standard Time
every Sunday from 4 into like 7 or 8
o'clock sometimes my show runs a little
bit longer we got more topics and we
play music and a lot of interviews I got
Craig Goldy coming in this weekend who I
play with him and I do and we have a new
record that came out called dream child
and yeah it's it's not having a great
time in and it's all thanks to you thank
you Jesus I almost pulled my earpiece
off there thank you you came in here and
you did it and you saw it you saw what
it does you saw I saw the 10 you feel
afterwards yeah you see how you come in
here sometimes this [ __ ] on your
shoulders and sometimes you come here
thinking about talking about something
and it goes somewhere completely
different and you like Jesus know by the
time I have them on next time we'll
forget all about that [ __ ] topic and
you know it's searching for if I can't
add something you're on earth another
reason why your podcast is so important
and I think podcast the good ones in
general is because you know one of the
other reason why I do the podcast is
because in the music community we've
lost a lot of dear friends and band
members
you know and I've sat during services
you know whether it's for Ronnie James
Dio or for for for for Lemmy you know
and of course Randy Rhoads many years
ago but you know to sit there and have
have people come up and speak and say
wonderful words about the dearly
departed and I'm sitting there I'm going
like what I I wish this person will be
sitting here now with us to listen to
these wonderful you know speeches from
all these friends and colleagues and I
thought you know this is something that
we can do with the podcast with a
podcast we can talk to each other you
know tell how much of an influence how
much love and respect we have for each
other and it's right there for eternity
you know for everybody to listen to and
share it you know hundred years from now
they'll be listening to this you know I
never even thought about it that way it
is really beautiful
you're a bad [ __ ] do you have
someone iTunes also no well you know the
bands that are played in a them you know
there's a my my two reason wreckers is
the the guests who record that came out
last year and and dream child okay no
I'm saying does your podcast get
released yeah well it's it's my podcast
which is separate which you did my
partner that's called six degrees or
value so that was called the - the - -
and the other one it's called six
degrees on radio yeah give rule you
listen beside that don't forget next
Thursday night Valentine's Day that's
all that's left in San Jose you get that
I'm [ __ ] - all right so a week from
today
I'm in Valentine's Day the still early
shows almost sold out the second shows
on its way do what you need to do then
the 22nd I'm in Treasure Island and Viva
Las Vegas
eight o'clock show with the great miss
Kate Quigley and then the same crew
rolls down the Tucson to the Fox Theatre
on the 23rd of February -
rock'n'roll with [ __ ] you to
sound Savage and don't forget I will not
be going to Tempe or Phoenix this will
be my only Arizona performance this year
so if you want to see your uncle Joey
and smoke weed and all that stuff come
on down the [ __ ] Tucson and that's it
and that's that I'll see you guys Monday
morning tip-top Magoo
I want to thank Rudy I want to thank the
[ __ ]
I want to thank ki sheet and I want to
thank all you [ __ ] that I love
to debt [ __ ] the [ __ ] Super Bowl if
you didn't cover go [ __ ] yourself
congratulations Lisa I thank you I know
you're doing with fans have a great
weekend I see you Monday morning ready
to rock love you all right I want to
thank Rudy Sarzo um I thank the Flying
Jew I'd also want to thank 23 of me why
because we live in a world where we have
access to data that gives us more
personal insights into who we are
23andme allows you to go beyond ancestry
to access more personalized insights
about you based on your DNA with more
than 125 genetic reports you can even
gain insights about your health
listen commit to a healthier you
inspired by your genes with the 23 amine
health and ancestry service you get more
than 125 genetic reports my experience
at 23andme was fantastic I keep getting
net notifications about cousins I didn't
even know about
now they hit me something about some
other health issues so and they just
tell you they point out different things
for you to look at all right like deep
sleep report if you're always suspected
that you feel more sleepy than others
after missing our night of sleep you
might be imagining things your genes
might be involved okay
alcohol flush reaction report does your
alcohol turn your chief suspect as a
glass of Road rose a you may have happen
or alcohol flush reaction learn about
the genetic factors that makes it
arbiter some people a process out for
you can probably thank or blame the
sweet tooth of yours on your relatives
and ancestors as well at least partition
apart partially 23andme house an
advocacy service can tell you if your
genetics predict you prefer sweet or
salty snacks and you believe that then
they got per saturated fat and weight
report that can tell you about how you
genetics may impact your body's response
to your diet all this another genetic
are you not so what that put 23andme is
giving me sort of what you do is this to
the church family you're looking for a
Valentine's Day present this is the one
a 23andme health and ancestry kit is the
perfect gift of Valentine's Day you buy
your kit today today right now you can
order today at 23andme dot-coms last
church again that's two three and me.com
slash church 23andme coms last church
that's the Valentine's Day present
you're looking for already oh yes I want
to thank on it for being solid with me
for five to six years
I knew Aubrey after that let me tell you
something the products are sensational
alpha brain if you don't like it they
give your money big money back guarantee
and they don't want the product back you
ever trying to your weed store you try
that [ __ ] maybe an F whatever [ __ ]
uh I don't even know Macy's go to go to
Macy's and go you know what I wore this
I danced for 22 hours to pants smell
like ten dead [ __ ] bodies but I want
to give it back to you see what they say
to you right now you tell them it don't
work for you they give me the money back
that's it that's a company who believes
in their product that's a company I want
to do business with go to Anna Tom right
now right now take a look at the
supplements there's got to be something
in there you've been thinking about
trying give it a shot
I'm the way out pressing church can get
10% off your order
delivered right to your house okay it's
that simple
excuse me I want to thank 23andme calm
and I want to thank on it I want to
thank Rudy Sarzo
I want to thank my man man the
[ __ ] and Kishu but most
importantly I want to thank you
[ __ ] for being family you
understand me you got the dates next
Valentine's Day that's all that's left
in San Jose do you know the way to San
Jose
you better [ __ ] note [ __ ]
next Thursday night 8 o'clock show 10
o'clock show will be going [ __ ] off
whatever prescription medic
you got bring it down it's gonna be like
a [ __ ] flea market down there and
that's it and that's that then the week
after that I'm a treasure on the nos
Vegas in the 22nd with Kate Quigley
another 23rd we invade Tucson Arizona
can't Vela the kidnappee is showing up
he confirmed it's all over
I left them two tickets at the door I
love your [ __ ] to see you next
week Monday morning nice and early
take that [ __ ] mealy